[Music]
all right thank you everybody for coming
but we have anybody who's still in the
memorabilia room the exhibition hall we
encourage you to come into the lecture
hall here and join us as we kick off the
third annual symposium on hybrid
scholarship at Yale University
Beyond Boundaries and this event is one
that is organized every year by a team
led by Cathy D Rose who's the manager of
the digital humanities lab this event
for the last three years really has been
the work of Cathy and it's been
supported by a great team of others
inside and outside the lab we're
especially happy to work alongside Yale
steam which is a student-led group here
at Yale University steam as most of you
know stands for stem plus Arts and
Humanities with a silent age we're
really excited to be working with them
and they've helped us in putting
together the program for today's events
so the exciting thing about Beyond
Boundaries of course is that it brings
together folks from all parts of the
scholarly spectrum at Yale University
and today you're gonna hear talks in
roundtable discussions for folks who
work in our robust museums galleries and
libraries organizations you're going to
hear from undergraduates graduate
students and faculty it's really
exciting to have all these parts of what
makes Yale University great here today
when Cathy asked me to welcome you all
to the hall I asked her what are the
things I need to do because you've
organized everything though you've
managed to get the room renovated all
this great program really excited what
out what could I possibly do that would
be useful and she said two things the
first thing to do is to make sure that
everybody's power point works so I'm
gonna be up here during the as we switch
between different keynote presentations
different lightning talks to make sure
that everybody's power point is working
well and she said the other thing you
need to do is to keep us on track so for
all of our wonderful lightning talk
presenters I'm gonna have little one
minute warnings
and then this is the cane that Yanks you
off the stage just so we can get through
everybody's work and so with that I'd
like to kick off our lightning talks
which are going to be presentations by
students and postdoctoral Associates on
subjects related to digital humanities
and steam projects here at Yale and the
first of our lightning talks is going to
be science stories using triple if' and
wiki data to create a linked data web
application and this is going to be a
presentation by Kenneth seals nut and
Kat Thornton so Ken and Kat hello
everyone thank you for allowing me to
speak at this opportunity my name is
Kenneth seals not I'm a senior computer
science major and I'm working in
concurrent with Kat Thornton who is a
CLI our fellow of computer science as
well as in the digital preservation
department and the library and what we
have been working on this this past year
is called science stories and what that
is is a application that we're gonna
leverage two resources that are widely
used by other projects here at Yale want
the first being wiki data and the second
being the triple ayah framework and I'll
touch a little bit on what each one is
as well as give a brief demo of the
application what we've built so far so
first of all I'd like to start by just
explaining the team again Kath thorn
Thornton is a CLI our fellow of computer
science I'm a senior undergrad student
here and this also doubles as my senior
project for the computer science
department and professor Benedict Brown
is our faculty advisor for this and so
I'll first give the like high-level
goals of the project and then break it
down into what things are being used
within the project so our first goal is
making a visual storytelling application
of academic research one thing that we
found with today's great resources of
computing as well as a lot of frameworks
that have been built for on the web is
that we can renovate how we go up
explaining our scientific and academic
research to the public one thing that we
found is we all do great research here
in these institutions but if someone
that doesn't have access to yells
catalog or another catalog of interest
it's really difficult and cumbersome to
find out this information so our first
goal was using images videos multimedia
and incorporating that with with our
academic research to paint the picture
of who we're actually researching and
provide more contextual information
there and then we're also going to
expand this out using the Wikimedia to
crowdsource some of the content one
thing that is really beneficial that of
you know a lot of research projects is
these stories can be told and a lot of
people don't have to do all of the busy
work of or all of the overhead work of
finding out all of this information that
other people have already researched so
if we can find a way to leverage more
crowdsource content incorporate that
with scholarly academic research we'll
be able to tell more about the person
and I'll also demo the how triple-i of
connects a lot of research institutions
together through this it allows for
authorship as well as annotations and
citations to be transferred from
institution to institution in in a very
safe way that allows a lot of
interactive interactivity for the users
as well and so ultimately the goal is to
bridge the gap between information
that's currently in print digitizing
that and putting it on the web and
making it accessible and the project as
a whole the main reason why we decided
to go about this is to celebrate 150
years of women at Yale which is coming
up next year and so what we wanted to do
is cat has been doing research on the
early women at Yale for the past two
years and she approached me with the
research that she's been doing and I
thought it was completely fascinating
and we both came to the
to the consensus that more people should
be able to know about this information
and not just be able to read a paper
about it but also be able to interact
with it so we're starting this project
on these first five women because they
are they have resources in a lot of
different areas only on Yale's campus
and so we're starting here to show that
we can leverage all of Gail's research
across the library as well as the
Peabody Museum as well as the department
and the faculty to all tell have a part
in telling the story not just a library
or not just a museum on campus and so
first I'll explain a little bit about
what wiki data is for those of you who
do not know it's a lot of people are
familiar with Wikipedia the English
Wikipedia wiki data is another one of
the projects that the Wikimedia
Foundation has adopted and what it is is
it's machine readable open link data and
that's a little long phrase but
essentially it allows people to create
these statements so for example this is
Grace hoppers item on wiki data right
now and so it's very clear statements of
what the like bare-bones data is about
this person and it goes on pretty pretty
lengthy but it just gives you an idea so
for example like instance of human image
and then it has the link to it sex
gender female so now we can feed that
information to a computer and it's all
unique identified with these identifiers
z' here and so that allows not only
humans to be able to read and understand
this information but also using
algorithms to curate this data as well
as to know that you've hit exactly what
you're looking for in terms of research
and then we're coupling this with using
triple I F which stands for the
International image in our
interoperability framework and what that
does is that it's a standard set of
image api's that a lot of research
institutions came together to determine
this is how we're going to
transfer the metadata about our pictures
when we're sharing these images so
instead of having people just copy and
paste or download images off the web
now you can export a JSON package that
has all of the metadata so that includes
the licensing the what's actually a
descriptions of what actually in the
images and outside of just a caption
links to where this resources and if for
example if it's digitized it we can link
back to what the actual collection is in
the in the archive that it's being
referenced to and so just I like this
picture on this on on the side here
because it shows how we can make this
practical for example this is a display
in Boston College right now where as you
know you can't really have the public
handle really old manuscripts and and
text so this would give you the
possibility to digitize that information
and have users flip through the book
page by page in a much more interactive
impersonal manner than then just by
staring at whatever page that's there
and so I will quickly just explain that
what our application does is it's going
to give you the ability to combine both
the information on the Wikimedia
Foundation YouTube videos as well as
books and any other content that we can
find all into one place and I'll just do
a brief demo of what that looks like
right now this is in a prototype phase
and so it takes you to this landing page
and right off the back it shows the
first five women that we're planning to
do research one and when you click on
them it shows you a little description
about who there is and it's pulling this
information from Wikipedia and then you
can view their story here and we decided
to go the slides method so you click
through and these are all not just for
one person this is just show the extent
of how the how the application is going
to work so this is all not for one
person but for example this is a triple
I up image viewer right here and you can
hover over who's in the image
understand more about the content and
click on it and and as well as have all
of the information on how to cite the
source and give credits and attributions
and then on the very last slide it'll
show you all of the current wiki data
information about them
and so yeah that's where we're headed
what we've built so far and we're
planning to present this the first
official demo of our first five science
stories at the women's faculty forum in
May as well as we'll be presenting the
full prototype at the triple I of
conference um in DC and we're submitting
a paper tonight actually for presenting
this to the international semantic web
conference in October so thank you guys
very much for your time
let's just jump ahead to Amy Juliana
who's going to be speaking on abroad but
now accessible via our educational tours
my name is Amy Giuliano I study religion
in the visual arts here at Yale
University and I wanted to begin by
inviting you to imagine that you're
standing at the threshold of st. Peter's
Basilica in Rome
you see bronze doors monumental bronze
doors towering at five times your height
above you and a guide beckons you into a
wide nave pierced with shafts of light
and immediately directs your attention
to the right where you see
Michelangelo's pietà as you walk around
this masterpiece and consider its
various angles the guide describes to
you the genius of Michelangelo and of
Renaissance humanism so what I just
described to you is the dream of one of
my students let's see her name's Alex
Alex longs to study abroad in Rome and
especially wants to study some of the
art and architecture of the city however
costs an opportunity prevent her from
doing so and Alex is not alone in fact
less than two percent of us college
students study abroad annually the
obstacles for most are cost opportunity
and access so I lived in Italy for
several years I'm an Italian citizen I
worked for years as an art historical
guide in Italy specifically in Rome but
some of the other other major cities I
currently teach at Sacred Heart
University in Fairfield Connecticut as
an adjunct professor and my frustration
was that I really wanted to share with
my students the transformative learning
experience of being within the living
classroom that certain incredible cities
provide so I felt frustrated that my
students were so many of my students
were missing
this transformative learning experience
so I decided to tackle the problem
head-on and I'll present to you my
proposed solution so two weeks ago I
went to Rome with some kind of high-tech
photography equipment and created 3d
virtual reality tours of some of the
major sites of artistic historic and
cultural significance around the city I
created 3d use using 3d high resolution
photography laser scanning 360
photography i virtually reconstructed
some of the interiors of these sites and
made a virtual tour so i'm coupling this
immersive visual experience with an
interactive virtual tour so students
feel as though they're walking through a
3d space and they can stop click and
explore points of interest that are
linked to audio-visual and written
content so here are some of the sites
that I covered while I was in Rome major
sites of art mostly are historical
significance but also historic and
cultural significance as well and I
chose to to share with you here we have
a classic for any art history course the
mausoleum of Santa Costanza is the 4th
century building and I'm just gonna go
through I won't give you the tour
because we don't have time but I can
explain to you some of the advantages of
using this type of technology as you can
see the student moves around the space
and can look all the way around
oops I can get the mouse work there we
go there's these buttons here that allow
you to zoom in for high resolution
detail you can zoom to different areas
there's a highlight reel you can kind of
see how it works here so this church
took about 2 hours to complete
this is a replica of the Sepulcher of
Costanza which is now in the Vatican
Museums sorry the mouse is a little
difficult on here but you can kind of
see what I mean here we have santa maria
sopra minerva which is a huge church
it's a basilica in rome it has works by
Michelangelo Philippe filippino lippi
the grave of Catherine of Siena gadget
n' and Frangelico here's a dollhouse
view and a floor plan you can see that
just as an example because I'm currently
working on creating the interactive
tours with audio visual and textual
elements added that I put a little tag
here and so the student can go into that
Chapel look at these 14th century
excuse me 15th century frescoes 1493
I brought my students in here
specifically because we were reading
Summa contra Gentiles by Thomas Aquinas
and here he is and it's an illustration
of that work so they explore these
frescoes you can zoom in for very high
detail if the computer doesn't crash
here we are and again you can see the
tag that I put in is just an example
there we go
you click and read all about this this
space these little areas on the floor
indicate places where you can zoom in
and out and kind of the next step in the
tour I'll bring you to the altar and
then we'll leave this space here's
Catherine of Siena's body underneath the
altar
and again I'm setting this up so that
students can see this in virtual reality
headsets so the experience will be
really three-dimensional and if you turn
around here whoops this is Christ the
Redeemer by Michelangelo so I at walking
you through this I'm trying to give a
sense of the advantages of using this
sort of tool pedagogical tool we jump
back to my presentation these are my
students exploring the Minerva as they
read Summa contra Gentiles and again
some of the advantages include this is
an immersive unforgettable experience
it's interactive it's engaging it does
what video cannot you're not passively
going through a space you're really
interacting with it you're exploring its
high high resolution you can explore
sculptures at different angles you can
consider their scale you consider the
context of yourself within this enormous
space and I'm my little plug to you is
please help me give access to students
to sites that they may otherwise never
experience and here are some of my
students I'm pleased just to conclude
I'm pleased to announce that I've
received a fellowship with SCI city to
work on this project for two months over
the summer and kind of get it off the
ground
make some more tours thank you
thanks so much to Amy and now we'll move
on to the media concept which is going
to be presented we've worked from Anna
Schekman and Zachary KITT thanks so much
to Peter and Kathy and Doug and everyone
at the th lab unfortunately my my
partner Zach KITT who is at the Jackson
Institute at Yale can't be here he was a
programmer before coming to Yale and
he's actually just about to graduate and
be a programmer again and he has been
working with me I'm a PhD candidate in
film and Media Studies and I am working
on a dissertation that is called the
media concept that's about the evolution
of the term media in the second half of
the 20th century specifically about when
when media entered the vernacular and
the ramifications that I had for
different culture industries so it's a
very literal project it's very word
based and so I actually was inspired to
work on it and think about it because I
was fooling around on Engram you are
which many of you may know just Google
Google interface here you'll see that
around you know after World War 2
there's the sky rocket in the in the in
the occurrences of the word media in all
the text that well all the text up to
2008 that Google Books has and so I was
interested in that phenomenon and also
interested in some of the different
iterations or offshoots of this of the
media concept and their and and their
evolutions over time and so I wandered
into the d-h lab and ask them about
Ngram viewer and also if there was a way
to have more control over it because it
it sort of just calls from this massive
amount of text that is that is Google
Books and if you actually go in and you
sort of it allows you to sort of click
around and see which books in particular
it's coming from and sometimes you'll
see that actually the metadata is wrong
and a book that it says
is from from 1940 as an in fact is in
fact a book from 1812 that was
republished in 1940 and you know it's
just not very precise and the fact that
it goes up to 2008 is also not ideal
because it doesn't go up to the present
and that is that is for all sorts of
reasons involving copyright and law so I
wanted more control over over over Ngram
viewer and Google Books and so I wanted
into the gh lab and asked them if I
could get that and they said that I
would have to build it essentially and
so I learned about a corpus I learned
about corpora about building your own
basically scraping text from all aspects
of the web or if it's not digitized
digitizing it and trying to create your
own your own database essentially that
then you can manipulate with various
different tools all of which I'm still
you know my learning curve I will admit
it's still very steep and I'm very
grateful to the patience of both sach my
assistant and and everyone at the th lab
so I'll tell you a little bit about what
Zak and I have done we started with the
Vogue corpus which is which is available
through the D H lab thankfully Yale has
that and so we have we have all of these
PDFs of articles from Vogue in the
twenty from the twentieth century and we
actually ran what is which a Google
algorithm called word to vet word
embedding models are as far as I can
tell the most interesting aspect of of
the textual digital humanities they're
just super exciting because they allow
they allow those who have any facilities
with with with the algorithm to track
the semantic and syntactic elationship
sub words over time how they do that is
fairly complicated and I can definitely
talk to you afterwards and also would
absolutely point you to the blog posts
of Ryan Hughes er from Stanford and Ben
Schmidt from Northeastern who are really
facile and agile at writing in between
in in between the sort of lexicons of
the humanities and
the Computer Sciences but basically they
take all of the words in your corpus and
they they plot them visually in a in a
in a space of n dimensions
multi-dimensional space and they the
theory behind this is you can actually
get related words from one query so I
can query media and find all the related
words and the principle is that these
semantic and syntactic evolutions will
be tracked by the company that a word
keeps over time and so here let's we
just a query media in this VOC corpus
you'll see one of the most amazing
interesting things for me to find is
that you know in in the in the 40s and
50s you you get a lot of let's say a not
very abstract pretty concrete nouns
manuscripts criticisms pallets all so
they're they're all narrow plural and
then as you move through time you start
to get adjectives and also that would
that would adjectives that might qualify
a singular like the consolidation of
media as a singular concept cultural
historical racial political religious to
me that signals I mean this is not this
is a small data set still vogue right
one you know the board medium might not
show up as much in vogue as it might end
a the New York Times but where we're
moving in that direction
Zack and I so to me that signals the
consolidation of a concept because you
have it's being qualified all of a
sudden as opposed to being substituted
and metaphorically or metonymically by
other other nouns so then here is where
things get really kind of psychedelic
and interesting so the what word Tyvek
allows you to play with is arithmetic
but linguistic arithmetic so you're able
for example to take to go into the
corpus and give it give it a give it a
an equation so let's say you wanted to
see to see how how sort of how
rigorous and extensive your your corpus
was if it was really good and again this
algorithm gets more precise than more
text there is so the bigger your corpus
is you could you could you could
theoretically put in this query King +
man - woman and you would most likely
get Queen because it's that smart which
is a little menacing but also really
interesting so in the in the vogue
corpus just for an example if we put in
this at this algorithm or this equation
you'll see that in nineteen forty fifty
sixty all of the first the most related
words were in fact Queen then
interestingly in nineteen seventy I'm
not sure why it's hairy and the third
most the most most related word is queen
but I also thought it was kind of
Awesome than in the vogue corpus the
most related word to that should be
queen is actually Thatcher in the
nineteen eighties just a glitch of
history um so then Zack and I were just
sort of playing around with more queries
like this with we have a big big list of
them and they're not I'm still not quite
sure what to do with them but this
interesting thing that you can do
essentially is if you say medium -
medium and you you throw that into the
computer you'll you'll hopefully be able
to approximate something like it will
take away let's say all of the words
that are that are both the most related
to media and both that really most
related to medium and you'll try to get
to a different type aspect element of
the concept to me I was thinking about
when I was chose these particular wants
to show you media - media media + arts
media - press I was trying to sort of
get at these different aspects of the
media concept its relation to the
concept of media more platform its
relationship to the phenomenon of mass
culture its relationship to to the the
proper that or to the article uh right
so so media - press I was sort of trying
to get at what if you take away that the
sort of very activity of the press is
there's some way to get this sort of
environmental or
atmospheric quality of media that's not
actually professional but is that but
it's more sort of experiential I mean
these are just aspirational aspirational
algorithms here but we've got some
really interesting weird stuff like
medium - medium the third most related
word is its pudgy Vic who is was a a was
the chairman of Conde Nast 4 from much
of the 20th century so that's
interesting and weird again this is just
the vogue corpus and so where exactly I
are going with this yeah this I thought
was interesting that media Plus arts
over time you start to get these sort of
what we would think of as mediums so
Zach and I started working on this with
the Atlantic and I'm actually now
working with Richard so at McGill who
has access to the Hadi trust databases
and we're actually just sort of trying
to put together a huge magazine corpus
in the 20th century and run word to Beck
on that but you'll see that the Atlantic
one for a variety of inter ayat e of
super interesting reasons just didn't
quite work in in that it's not big
enough we were only able to just because
of time and resources
Zack's and mine not the DHS okay
we were not actually able to get all of
the text from the Atlantic but just the
words that just the text that had the
word media in them and that just wasn't
enough text for the word Tyvek algorithm
to be effective so you get these really
and the way we know that essentially
first of all the way you know that is it
before 1960 there's just not even enough
text there at all to even make to have
data also none of these are Queens
sometimes country maintain forage Bishop
there's just it just didn't it just
didn't quite work so hopefully as we
continue this project and we get a
bigger and bigger corpus and two people
actually we're hoping to actually be
able to approximate the way that the
media talked about media in the 20th
century
so is
thanks so much and now I think having
failed once at being able to get the
PowerPoint working correctly I think we
now can invite up jasker Feinberg to
talk about co education at Yale through
the eyes of the pioneer that managed to
get it working Thank You jasmine so
first of all thank you all for being
here
obviously I'm a sophomore undergraduate
at Yale studying mechanical engineering
and actually did this project as part of
a digital humanities class at Yale which
is a seminar offered to all
undergraduates I believe some of the
teachers of that actual class are in the
audience but I won't embarrass them by
pointing at them specifically so the
goal of this project was to show how
Yale became co-educational but our true
goal was to show how the use of digital
multimedia could really bring that
process to life and given the time frame
I want to dive right into that so our
goal was to not just sort of give it a
textbook history of Yale's process the
co-education but to really sort of make
our audience feel a lot of the actual
struggles discrimination and image the
context of this era and we chose to do
that by focusing on one person in
particular as opposed to showing a
broader spectrum that person happened to
be Margaret Homans who is currently an
English professor here and was member of
the second class of women at Yale but
before giving a full rundown of her
story I assume who sort of established
the context of co-education at Yale so
as some of you may or may not know yield
actually did not become co-educational
until 1969 and it sort of became
co-educational as the women's movement
and broader movements at Yale itself
began to strongly push for it but it
should be noted that Yale was not
exactly a pioneer despite the title of
this project in the field of
co-education by 1897 56 percent of all
institutions were already co-educational
by the time that Yale actually became
co-educational that number was in the 80
percents so to give sort of a map
this is Yale obviously the first school
to become co-educational is Oberlin in
1837 once Oberlin became co-educational
then about nine more universities became
co-educational in the 1850s including
Baylor Lawrence Antioch but the movement
still not started it was mostly small
colleges and the true shift towards co
education had not begun but that became
much more pronounced with the beginning
of the land-grant universities
especially in the western region which
if you don't know our large public
institutions that usually began
co-educational and that really drove the
push HBCUs as well began become
co-educational in the late 1800s now if
we fast forward a little bit by 1965
most schools had become co-educational
that included Harvard UPenn many of the
schools in the West such as Stanford
Caltech etc and about overall I think 84
percent of colleges were co-educational
so by the time ye'll actually became
co-educational in 1969 they were far
behind most of their peers this was not
necessarily a great achievement but
nonetheless they had a very large
transition to make shifting a school
from Seoul email to a co-educational
institution is no easy transition and
that's really what we wanted to focus on
through the eyes of Margaret Homans
herself and looking at her experiences
so with that in mind Margaret Howe Muntz
starting with her childhood was born in
Boston and she actually attended
something called the Commonwealth school
which is a small private school in
Boston and she credits that with sort of
her ability to get into a place like he
also early become one of the first
members of her class obviously she had
privileges that many other did not many
other women did not have during that era
and she actually taught it she decided
to attend you not really because it had
just become co-educational but just
because of the strength of its academic
programs
she had a teacher in high school who had
gone to Neal for English
he sort of described her sort of a
utopia for the English language and
studies of it so she chose you mostly
just for its academic achievements and
the fact that it become co-educational
allowed her to do that but it was not
that she desire to be a pioneer she
simply wanted to study English so Yale
to give a very very brief history given
the time constraint decided to admit
women in the 1960s after a variety of
student protests so the main factor that
shifted during this era was that Yale's
actual admission criterion began to
shift
president Kingman Brewster decided to
begin to admit people based on merit as
opposed to family connections wealth etc
which seems of a very obvious decision
to us at the time but earlier in this
era merit had been a factor but not the
main factor and admissions and so once
merit became the true determining factor
between who was admitted and not
admitted then many more people from
public institutions public high schools
Western high schools began to attend
Yale and that's what had produced the
demographic shift amongst the men at
Yale and eventually that led to protests
into what's called Mayday which was a
series of protests that tried to show
Akemi and brewster that the student body
was behind this shift towards
co-education so upon feeling a lot of
student pressure faculty finally decided
to get behind this and they decided to
create proposals etc and finally in 1969
ye'll decided to become co-educational
and again to establish some context this
shift was not easy we included the
multimedia here of letters that were
sent to kingman brewster some calling
women indignant for showing their knees
and thighs and public calling them
prostitutes if they were to even show
any sort of skin many letters saying
that if women dominated the a leo would
end you know they wanted their sons to
being able to go to Yale and they could
not do that if women somehow attended so
well the time hormones got here it was
not exactly a easy transition
and I think that's really reflected in
her anecdotes and her stories so
starting with academics she describes
being used to being in a simply kawatche
occasional environment to her it was not
significant that women were now in these
classes but to many of the boys it was
she described being in a classroom
especially in her English classes and
being one of only one or two women there
and how the pressure was always on her
to speak whenever any topic related to
femininity came up and how outside of
that she felt very reticent to speak she
did not feel as though she could really
develop a voice one of the things that
she described was lucky was being in
classrooms with some female professors
who actually encouraged her to study
female literature and feminist critique
and she felt like that was really the
main academic experience as opposed to
reading just books like what she
described as and I quote dead white men
outside of the classroom Hmong's became
involved heavily in the women's abortion
referral center at Yale which is
currently in the it's in the it was
formerly in what is now the a fam house
if any of you know where that is
she also briefly joined the glee club
and several other clubs on campus
although she felt like she was usually
admitted to those clubs solely because
she was a woman and most of the clubs at
the time had a quota where they were
supposed to try to achieve equal gender
balance so there was a lot of pressure
to admit women some of the experiences
that I thought were most poignant
however were to sir personal experiences
so women were all housed in Vanderbilt
Hall during this era and there was a
glass door to Vanderbilt hall and
Hmong's described that door is being
symbolic where she felt as the women
could see sort of the freedom they were
promised in co-education but they
couldn't actually achieve it because
there was a guard at that door who
wouldn't let them out at night etc
whereas none of the other halls had a
guard or such a door another experience
she mentioned was how she sewed herself
what she described as a uniform which is
essentially a long dress and she wore
that every day to essentially cover up
any part of her body because she was not
used to being sort of viewed as a female
body as opposed to just another student
and she wanted to hide herself and this
uniform was a way for her to do that
and finally she actually described how
she refused to walk down the graduation
hallway in her cap and gown because she
felt as though that was encouraging in
all-male tradition and she wanted to
rebell and on the whole I would not
describe her dream Suzanne is easy but
she was able to adapt to Yale in fine
pencils where she was comfortable this
heat map shows areas on campus where she
felt comfortable and uncomfortable and
by sort of carving out certain areas on
campus she was able to sort of adapt
find other women and in create an
environment in which she could learn but
obviously looking forward to her
experiences I think are emblematic of
the path yourself to go to achieve
trucco education at Yale and I just want
to leave you with the idea of like what
does co-education mean is it truly just
having women in our classrooms or is it
allowing a fully immersive and equal
educational experience and how can we
achieve that thank you very much
[Applause]
thanks very much to Jasper and now I'd
like to invite Nina warszawa up who is
going to speak on the relationship
between the style and impact of judicial
opinions okay first of all thank you so
much to the digital humanities lab for
all of the help they've given me all the
support they've given me with my
research and thanks especially to Doug
Duhon who has helped me tirelessly with
the minutiae of this project and related
work I'm incredibly grateful I'm going
to be talking about the relationship
between the style and impact of judicial
opinions so judicial opinions are the
texts that judges write in order to
explain and justify their decisions and
these texts make up the common law when
judges decide new cases they have a
legal duty to follow the rules and
reasoning set out in previous opinions
the more cases that a previous opinion
appears in the more influence it has on
the common law so I examine whether and
how an opinion style is related to its
impact to its legal impact my results
show that if that an opinion style is a
significant predictor of its impact
where impact is measured by the number
of cases that will cite it so to give
you a brief overview of my approach my
data set includes almost all majority
opinions from the 10th Circuit Court of
Appeals during a 12-year period this
court is an important federal appellate
court which answers to the US Supreme
Court it's also the court where Neil
Gorsuch served as a judge before joining
the Supreme Court last year so first I
derived a set of measurable stylistic
features from the literature on judicial
writing I then used natural language
processing to detect and measure these
features in each of my opinions
my dependent variable is the number of
cases that cite to the opinion and I use
this as a measure of an opinions impact
on case law or its power as a precedent
my independent variables on the top I've
listed my stylistic features of interest
on the bottom are my control variables
for the most part on the stylistic
features I measure these on a per word
basis meaning that for example with
citations to Authority I counted how
many times an opinion cites statutes and
other cases per word first I'll give you
an overview of my data using some charts
to give you a sense of what they look
like and then I'll show my statistical
model and my statistical results so here
you can see how judges line up on
lexical diversity lexical diversity is
basically the range of vocabulary of an
opinion it's simply the number of unique
words over the total words so you can
see here that the judges range from
about 20% unique words to 28% unique
words male judges are in blue female
judges are in maroon and Gorsuch is
highlighted in red
here's informality this is basically
informal usage per word and you can see
here that the judges range from about
zero on informality to about point zero
one which means one per 100 words is
informal with Gorsuch at the high end
here's certainty so this is certainty
terms expressing certainty per word so
judges range on this from about one to
three point five certainty terms per
1000 words and you can see the female
judges clustering on the low end of
certainty what's interesting is they
also cluster it on the low end of
hesitancy so these this represents
hesitant or tentative expressions and
Gorsuch again is on on the high end of
this so here is my main statistical
model this is a mixed model which is a
type of regression that suits the
structure of my data to give you a
summary in my results show that
stylistic quality is run with the cases
impact or presidential power and
systematic ways my style variables are
on the top and the blue rectangle all of
these variables all these stylistic
features with the exception of passive
voice our statistics statistically
significant predictors of citations and
recall that my dependent variable is the
number of cases that cite the opinion
most of these factors are positively
related to citations but two of them
certainty and informality are negative
predictors of citations so I'll take my
remaining time to talk through these
results since it's not altogether
obvious I think just from looking at the
values what they mean because for one my
dependent variable is log transformed so
as word count goes up by one citing
cases goes up by sorry as we're count
goes up by one percent citing cases also
goes up by about one percent as reading
level goes up by one grade-level
citations goes up by 5% as lexical
diversity goes up by one percent sites
go up by two percent as Authority per
word goes up by point zero one so this
means one additional citation to us to a
case or statute per 100 words cites goes
up by 27 percent as references to people
by proper naming goes up by 1 in 100
citing cases goes up by 20 percent and
that's the same for references to lid
against by technical terms plaintiff or
defendant so it seems that just
referring to people regardless of how is
a good thing for citations a certainty
per word goes up by point zero zero one
citing cases goes down by 4% but as
hesitancy goes up by the same amount one
in 1,000 sighting cases goes up so
certainty is a negative predictor of
citations but hesitancy is a positive
predictor semi-colons goes up by 1 in
1,000 sites goes up by 3% and then as
informality per word goes up by 1 in 100
citing cases goes down by 20% so
informality is strongly negatively
related with citations so to just wrap
up I also ran a regression with a normal
regression with judged judge fixed
effects which generated very similar
results to this model the fixed effects
model shows that my variables explained
45 percent of the variance and citations
and that my stylistic variables alone
just these 11 stylistic features explain
15% of the variance in the number of
cases that will cite an opinion thank
you
[Applause]
thanks very much to Nina and now I'd
like to invite up participants that our
project called digital humanity
Jessica Embry ambrosio and Maria they're
gargouille Julia apologies for that good
morning everyone my name is Jessica
Morrison and I'm a junior majoring in
computer science hi my name is Maria
gradual oh and I'm also junior majoring
in statistics in data science and
Spanish and where the co-presidents of
Yale code for good today we're
presenting on what we call digital
humanity and we'd like to begin with
this brief anecdote the first program
most people write is a simple hello
world it's time we start seriously
considering and talking about the impact
that our code can and does have on the
world in which we live so as a club we
have come to defined coding for good as
applying software tools and techniques
to solve problems that our community or
society faces so what this means is that
we stick to design and develop programs
and our only address the technical
aspects of problems but also consider
the impact that these technologies will
have on the people who make use of them
is the impact positive does it benefit
them beyond just merely solving a
technical issue so you might be asking
now how do you do that
so we do this by recruiting teams of
four to six students to work in
collaboration with nonprofit
organizations yell student groups or
local government agencies to address
socially conscious problems and these
can cover all types of different things
there's no one problem that is or is not
socially conscious many things are
different in many ways we currently have
three project teams two of whose work
we'd like to highlight today so our
first project is the road sign manager
and for this project we partnered with
make him in a locker maker space in
downtown New Haven and then you have any
permanent transportation to address
transportation traffic issues the main
problem to solve here was that commuters
did not know where how many parking
spaces were available at a given
location to solve this problem make even
modify the Hardware of multiple road
signs so that they could be programmable
nevertheless someone still had to go
down to the road sign and change it
manually
to this and our team built a web
application that connects the road sign
so that officials can simply access the
web application and update any
information on the road sign in
real-time in addition to improving the
parking system in New Haven this
software also provides a great mechanism
for important updates in case of
emergencies if you want to hear more
about this project the team who worked
on it will be later presenting in during
the poster session the next project that
we'd like to talk about today has been
done in collaboration with ku baby so
cushy baby is actually a nonprofit
organization founded at Yale started in
the CID as part of a class project for I
think a mechanical engineering course a
few years ago it operates in India in
founding their organization the co shoe
baby team sought to address issues in
the indian medical system currently
doctors are required to keep paper
records an issue with these records they
need to travel with the doctors as they
move they often become just organized
and files get lost and this is
particularly problematic for women and
their newborn children the issue with
this is that they need to see doctors at
certain points post birth and if doctors
are losing files there's no record of
which vaccinations they've received when
they've gotten past appointments so to
deal with this because she BBT and made
a simple wearable it's a little necklace
that the child wears and it stores all
their information in it when doctors go
to see the children and their mothers
they can simply load their data into a
web application if they have internet
access and if not there's an Android app
multiple people can view the information
at when they're seeing the child I'll
fly whenever they need to and this is
really helpful because it deals with the
missing record issue and also lets
people look at information in various
places the code for good team has been
contributing to this project by helping
because she baby updates some of their
models one of the big things that the
team cares about is risk assessment they
like to triage their patients so that
newborns and their mothers were
particularly high risk for various types
of health issues can be viewed according
to the relevant part
just a little image of what the
dashboard of because she be the
application looks like now you might be
asking yourself why do we do this why I
was quit for good found it so code for
good was founded last spring the reason
it was founded is because there was no
real space available on campus for
technically inclined students to work on
socially conscious problems so there are
a lot of wonderful places where our
students can go and work out but the
impact that they can make their will
really reach the people who need our
help the most so this is your typical
job bird these are the kind of companies
that we usually see that any CS or data
science major will look at and you know
what these are wonderful places to work
out they to work at they are doing
amazing stuff but the only present a
personal image of what can we do with
what can be done with technology and to
end off today we'd like to leave you all
with a question or perhaps a challenge
how can you do more good with the
technology that you use or know how to
use so if you have an answer to this
question or just want to share your
ideas with us please come to us at code
for good at Yale dot e-d-u
thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Jessica and Maria and to all
of our presenters during this first
initial lightning talks a part of the
conference I think at this point I'd
like to invite up members of our
roundtable discussion
you
[Music]